je ne pensais pas que le problème de
l'adoption et péter était aussi qu il a
l'art chiffres datent de la fin des
années 70 via l'époque déjà adopté un
enfant était une démarche longue et
épuisante est pratiquement impossible
pour les personnes seules en témoigne
cette mère de famille célibataire en
1974 obligé d'aller au vietnam pour
adopter
c'est très difficile et je crois que
c'est encore plus difficile que pour les
coûts j'étais prête à faire n'importe
quoi aller n'importe quel pays pour
avoir un enfant
les célibataires ne sont pas les seuls
concernés par cette galère même les
couples mariés font face à des refus à
l'image d'anne et jean-jacques chaussard
eux aussi contraints d'aller adopter au
cambodge en 2003 nous avons été refusée
pour des critères tels que l'âge tels
que aussi des convictions religieuses ou
alors pour des problèmes également de
finance pas assez de salaire voilà autre
cas de figure qui commence à être
médiatisé au début des années 2000 les
personnes homosexuelles très souvent
discriminées en 2009
ce couple de femmes cherchent
désespérément à adopter mais le conseil
général du jura le refus
systématiquement l'agrément
indispensable pour entamer les démarches
et à 9 ans on était déjà ici dans ce
même tribunal a expliqué les mêmes
choses c'est à dire notre désir d'enfant
l'envy de rendement de rendre un enfant
heureux on aller jusqu'à la cour
européenne et d'un conte et retrouve
retombées sur la première marche
d'escalier
le mariage homosexuel est autorisé en
2013 ouvrant la voie à l'adoption pour
les couples de même sexe une proposition
de loi est approuvée en première lecture
par l'assemblée nationale ces derniers
jours elle prévoit d'abaisser l'âge pour
adopter de 28 à 26 ans et d'ouvrir
l'adoption aux couples pacsés et aux
concubins
[Musique]